and his wife Romina couldn't wait for
the birth of their first child a boy
but when Romina went into labor
everything went wrong
eight hours after the child was born he
died of asphyxiation and his mother
barely survived
the couple blames their child's death on
the hospital's lack of resources to deal
with medical emergencies ultimately
because funds are siphoned off by
corruption
Romina is still in hospital where
patients have to provide their own
medicine syringes and even water
we're willing to do what it takes to see
that Justice is served this can't stay
in impunity they can't get away with
this because my son had the right to
live
nearby we find an elementary school that
is so underfunded that there are no
classrooms for the older children they
study Outdoors where the smaller
students play
Paraguay is widely known as one of the
most corrupt countries in Latin America
a country with impressive wealth but in
the hands of only very few with
political power
in January the U.S imposed new sanctions
against former president oracio cartes
for quote involvement in significant
corruption after U.S Secretary of State
Anthony blinken accused him of links to
drug trafficking and terrorist
organizations
denies the charges but in Paraguay they
haven't come as a surprise
no no people are not surprised because
the common sort of response has been we
knew it all the time except we didn't
want to you know the the the Attorney
General didn't react the Judiciary was
quiet the police didn't do anything in
this inner city slum children play in
the mud alongside pigs the small
community moved here a few months ago
when their neighborhood was flooded
families who live here have had to build
these Shacks with their own hands as in
so many parts of Paraguay here the
absence of the state is obvious
everywhere you look except during
election time when candidates like this
one come calling to ask for people's
votes
65 year old Eliana says they've always
been poor and abandoned by politicians
and that Sunday's elections won't change
anything
they always buy our votes they give you
money that's why no one elects someone
who will improve things that's all I can
say in my life it's a vicious circle
made easier by resignation a belief that
Decades of corruption is just another
cross that those who suffer the most
from it simply have to bear Lucian human
Al Jazeera Asuncion Paraguay